you talked about how we put romantic  love on a pedestal  and sometimes our cups run us over and  we shouldn't lose sight of all the love  we have  just in case there's not that romantic  love in the picture too and that we as a  society have built this up to such Grand  proportions that some people think that  they're lacking if they don't have that  love I do feel my cup runneth over my  life is so fulfilling and I almost ask  myself sometimes because you don't have  that romantic love is something missing  I don't feel like it does but I almost  needed permission or I needed an answer  to just feel whole and the one you gave  me about how we put romantic love on a  pedestal so eye-opening for me oh thank  you